hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round five of the
world rapid championship 2021 it's uh
the always unpleasant alexa ashore
versus magnus carlsen and uh well it
it's a game where magnus deliberately uh
goes into a bad position just because he
probably knows how to play it a little
bit better than than shiro you'll see
what i mean by this so shiro has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 we
have e5 by magnus
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
b5 so just a nice rule lopez with a6
morpheus defense uh bishop to a4 and now
knight to f6 we have castles and bishop
to e7 d3
and b5 attacking the bishop here we have
bishop to b3 and magnus castles we have
a4 so this is all very standard stuff
we're going after the b5 pawn rook to b8
captures captures and knight to c3 now
and magnus plays bishop d6 preparing to
develop his light square bishop shiro
goes knight to d5 saying are you maybe
interested in a trait here and magnus
captures on d5 captures captures and now
all right the position of course is a
known one but what black will do here is
play knight to d4 and then white will
capture for example black captures and
you get this very weird
uh looking structure in the center and
the game goes on however magnus does not
go knight to d4 he goes knight to b4 and
this is where uh the fun really starts
uh
uh
as it's it's a very weird square to
place your knight because shiro just
plays c3 and he asks magnus what do you
do with the knight uh you can't go d5
you can't go c6 the only square you have
is the a6 square so this is what magnus
plays and now uh there is a game where
bishop to c 2 was played but here shirov
says all right you are not freeing that
knight with knight c5 i'm just going to
play d4 and it is now as of move 14 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see uh how magnus intends to bring this
knight back into the game we have bishop
to f6 uh now
defending the e5 square d captures an e5
d captures on e5 and now bishop to e3
again uh taking care of that c5 square
we have queen to d6 by magnus he now
wants to get the knight to c5 uh and now
we have knight the d2 by sheriff also
very interesting was bishop to c2 it's
just a useful piece to have on this
diagonal maybe you can even
double up here later on but also you are
preparing b4 if white can get b4 in
that's going to be incredible uh for
white you're going to
control the a5 square the the c5 square
so it's going to be really really tricky
for this knight to get into the game and
um oh okay now the queen defends it so
you can develop your bishop you don't
have to worry about rook captures on a6
but still bishop to c2 followed by b4
definitely uh what white should do but
okay knight to d2 by shiro and now
bishop back to e7 gaining more control
over c5 and uh maybe having some ideas
of uh pushing the f pawn we have f4 by a
share of e captures on it for bishop
captures and queen to b6 check king to
h1 and finally magnus gets the knight
into the game knight to c5 attacking the
bishop here shiro goes bishop to c2 and
now we have bishop to b7 so magnus also
enjoying his bishop on this long
diagonal
and if you load this position to an
engine they will tell you white is
completely or well maybe not completely
but white should be winning here
although it's not all that clear why but
those are two difficult questions to
answer uh in a rapid game uh why the
engine just says queen f3 incredibly
strong for white uh but sheriff played
queen to e1 and it it kind of makes
sense because you really don't
understand what the queen is doing on f3
aside from this and i mean that doesn't
look pleasant but queen e1 followed by
queen to g3 that is something that we
can relate then maybe bishop to h6 can
come and an attack is already happening
so here magnus quickly shifts this rook
over to the e file aligns it with the
queen queen to g3
and now as uh the d5 pawn is hanging
okay your c6 7 pawn is hanging
but it's not as important uh bishop
captures on d5 by magnus and now bishop
captures on c7 again it is a question
maybe a bit too hard to answer for a
rapid game but maybe throw in a b4 here
and there so bishop captures on c7
attacking the queen and now queen to c6
threatening bishop captures on g2 with
check because then if the queen captures
you can pick up the bishop on c7 so
sheriff brings the bishop back with
bishop to e5 now shiro is threatening
checkmate on g7 and magnus has to figure
out how to defend this does he go 96
does he go g6 f6 or or whatever
he plays f6 uh you'll always
have to be
very careful when you play a move like
this but he feels very confident bishop
to f4 and now only now 96 attacking the
bishop so queen to h3
attacking the h7 pawn and only now
magnus plays g6 we have bishop to h6
attacking the rook and now again there
are a couple of nice ideas you can play
here but magnus goes knight to g5 he
attacks the white queen here and it's
not all that
easy to figure out how to go about this
position especially since shiro is very
low on the clock magnus has some nine
minutes on the clock i think shiro is
two or three minutes on the clock i
think closer to two and the the thing is
if you play some like let's say queen g3
then bishop d6 we continue piling up on
the white queen queen g4 let's say and
now rook to e3 and it's a complete mess
of a position but it's definitely not
pleasant for this white queen here so
for example you capture the rook h5 and
how are you defending the g2 pawn
there's really no good move you can make
here so instead after knight g5 we have
bishop captures eliminating this very
strong piece f captures on g5 and now
bishop to b3 yeah offering more trades
bishop captures on b3 knight captures we
have rook captures on f1 with check rook
captures on f1 and now bishop to f6 and
if you look at the position now the
material is completely equal uh it's a
bishop for a knight uh but uh as the
game is on both sides of the board uh a
bishop tends to be a little better than
a knight so here we have queen to d3 uh
and now g4 but as you know uh when uh
time on the clock is very low and nice
use the knights are usually a little bit
better than bishops because they you
know very unpredictable when they jump
around the board so knight to d4 and
here queen to c4 magnus offers a queen
trade and he wants to go into the end
game queen captures on c4b captures and
now knight to b5 uh we rook to e2 and
now the situation on the clock is shiro
has some one minute on the clock magnus
two minutes on the clock and your b2
pawn is hanging so how do you defend it
well first we have g3
what's uh what's the idea here well if
you go after the
pawn you're gonna lose the bishop and
obviously you could not capture the
bishop right away because then you're
getting checkmated so that's why i
should sheriff had to prevent this by
playing g3 we have bishop to e7 now
preparing to grab the b2 pawn and knight
the a3 now now you are defending it by
attacking the uh c for pawn now magnus
could capture on b2 but he could also
capture an a3 yeah if you capture on a3
for example b captures and now let's say
you go after this spawn uh it's pretty
much a draw just rook a1 white will
start pushing this pawn if you capture
here we're gonna play a4 now rook b3
black also wants to start pushing his
past pawn for example a5 c3
and now you can't really
afford a move like c2 and rook to b1
otherwise black wins so you're gonna
have to move the rook away from the a
pawn then black will attack the a pawn
and this is a draw so after this knight
to a3 magnus goes rook captures on b2
instead and now knight captures on c4
rook to e2 uh and now knight to b6 we
have king to g7
knight to d5 now attacking the bishop
bishop the d6 and now knight to f4
attacking the rook here rook to e3
attacking the pawn and now king to g2
he's giving up the pawn and although the
pawn can be captured magnus decides
against it for the moment he first
regards the h5 uh the g4 pawn you could
capture on c3 for example let's say 96
king j8 now rook f2 uh it's still very
hard for for black to make any progress
here but magnus says there's no rush
it's um
if if i want to capture this pawn i will
capture it at some point rook to f2 and
now rook captures on c3 and now magnus
is up a pawn but it's here a double g
pawn and it's very unlikely that you
will be able to
do something about this so 96 check king
to h6 now comes rook to d2 putting
pressure on the bishop
bishop to e5 and now rook to e2 we have
bishop back to b8 and now rook to b2
again putting pressure on the bishop
bishop to a7 and now rook to a2 again
following the bishop bishop to e3 and
now rook to e2 but now the bishop is
defended so magnus continues pushing g5
we ignite the c7 saying okay you capture
my knight i'm going to capture the
bishop and then we agree to a draw uh
magnus says rook to d3 uh we have knight
to d5 attacking the bishop and bishop to
d4 so still keeping the
the tension uh knight the e7 now with
some ideas of knight f5 check maybe we
can pick up the bishop this way so just
bishop the c5
we have brooke the e5 attacking the
bishop rook the d2 check trying to grab
hold of the h2 pawn but still your
bishop is hanging so first you have to
tend to that king to f1 now comes rook
to c2 we defend our bishop but still
putting uh some pressure on the h2 pawn
and it's not easy for the white king to
defend it you can't uh cross the g1
square or the g2 square the rook defends
that so here we have knight to f5 check
and this is a
a bad move by shiro what you should do
is probably some like rook to e6
checking to h7 and i'll go rook to c6
and now you no longer have any problems
you will
well
at least you will trade a piece so you
can bring your night summer for example
night your night here night here and
then you will force a trade um
and it's very unlikely that uh magnus
will be able to push for anything here
but knights the f5 check was played and
this now makes it uh very easy for
magnus to win this game magnus just
plays king to g6 and now there is really
nothing you can do here with the white
pieces and to make matters worse uh
shirov played knight to e3 and before he
hit the clock his time ran out and
basically was in this position that he
lost on time
but position is completely winning for
magnus because magnus will just capture
and after captures rook captures on h2
and now he has three pawns against one
he will just for example push this and
win the game
but interestingly uh even if you play
something like the best defense let's
say king the e1 and okay the rook still
can't capture the h2 pawn because the
bishop would hang
king f6 we attacked the rook after rook
king rook d5 king e6 now both the rook
and the knight are attacked and there
really isn't anything here after knight
before check you you're going to fork
the king and the rook we're going to
play characters captures magnus will
still capture the h2 pawn and we're
getting pretty much the exact same
position as the one that happened in the
game only you know uh a little bit
differently uh and uh of course uh
ashiro would would have resigned here as
well uh
instead here uh where his time ran out
uh but yeah very nicely done by magnus
and he finishes day one with four and a
half out of five which is not bad as one
of the games uh that could end
in a five out of five was still uh being
played uh while i was recording in this
video the one uh duda was playing
against uh joe bava extremely crazy game
i think that's definitely the one i'm
showing next so i even i don't know uh
the results of that game until i ended
this video uh so yeah uh that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank marcus busan our czech made
epilepsy catherine matriarch jack
schroeder and jeffrey ryden or for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
amazing event
until it ends thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day